it's an honor today to be here I think
Roger has just arrived to introduce
Roger Waters as well as making brilliant
music Roger has been speaking out for
the rights of men and women for many
years and I thank him warmly for
initiating this extraordinary event to
celebrate and defend Julian Assange
Roger regards Julian as a hero and so do
i and and it'll be a pleasure to
introduce Julian's brother Gabriel who
is here from Melbourne Gabriel went with
me recently to visit Julian and Belmarsh
prison and was deeply moved by the
treatment of his brother behind us here
of course is the Home Office the polite
name for britain's interior ministry the
behavior of the british government
towards julian assange is a disgrace a
profanity on the very notion of human
rights it's no exaggeration to say that
the treatment and persecution of Julian
Assange is the way dictatorships treat a
political prisoner
there is one reason for this Julian and
WikiLeaks have performed a historic
public service by giving millions of
people facts and why and how their
governments deceive them secretly and
often illegally why they invade
countries why they spy on us Julian has
singled out for special treatment for
one reason only he is a truth teller his
case is meant to send a warning to every
journalist and every publisher the kind
of warning that has no place in a
democracy I spoke to Julian at the
weekend
he'd been just allowed to have his first
proper exercise he was allowed to pace
up and down in a small bitumen yard
however at Belmarsh prison they have a
sense of humor on the walls facing the
so called exercise yard a happy clappy
words about the blades of grass beneath
your feet but there's no grass Julian is
locked up for more than 21 hours
sometimes longer it's four months four
months since he was dragged out of the
Ecuadorian Embassy literally in brutal
contravention of international law it's
four months and he is still denied the
documents and the basic tools to prepare
his case against an outrageous demand
for his extradition to the United States
where he faces incarceration and almost
certainly torture and yet he is not
allowed today to call his American
lawyers he is not allowed access to
vital documents he is not allowed access
to a computer
he's confined in a single cell in the
hospital wing where he has isolated most
of the time from other people all this
all this because he infringed bail a
bail order the merest of offenses and he
sought political asylum from the threat
to his life that awaited him in Trump's
America when I asked Julian what he'd
like me to say today he was adamant say
it's not just me
it's much wider it's all of us it's all
journalists and all publishers who do
their job who are in danger in other
words the danger Julian Assange faces
can easily spread to the present and
past editors of The Guardian The New
York Times
Der Spiegel L pays in Spain the Sydney
Morning Herald and many other newspapers
and media outlets around the world that
published the WikiLeaks revelations
about the lies and crimes of our
governments never before in my career as
a journalist have I known such an attack
on our most basic freedom to publish and
to know the message is loud and clear be
careful or you too will end up in an
American hellhole journalism is not a
crime in the United States not yet but
if Julian is extradited and convicted it
will become a crime journalism that does
its job and tells people what
governments do behind their backs in
their name
Julian is not an American he is an
Australian citizen WikiLeaks which he
founded is not a us-based publication
but the meaning of his extradition could
not be clearer no matter who you are or
where you are if you expose the crimes
of government you'll be hunted down
kidnapped and sent to the US as a spy 17
out of the 18 charges that Julian faces
in America relate to the routine work of
an investigative journalist which is
protected under the First Amendment of
the US Constitution the 18th charge
about hacking doesn't even relate to him
and even the prosecution over there say
that the whole thing is a sham the US
prosecutors know it's a sham a federal
judge recently declared effectively it's
a sham
the British government know it's a sham
the Australian government knows it's a
sham that's why Julian has locked up
more than 21 hours a day in a
maximum-security prison and treated
worse than a murderer why is that why is
he not protected by international law as
the United Nations working party has
demanded he is to be made an example
that's why what happens to Julian
Assange and the Chelsea Manning is meant
to intimidate us too and frighten us
into silence and the moment that we fall
silent it's over by defending Julian
Assange we defend our most sacred rights
speak up now or wake up one morning to
the silence of a new kind of tyranny
the choice is ours thank you
[Applause]
you